hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen zu einem spiel dieses spiel
heißt sonicwall und wir spielen das
jetzt wir können hier entweder sonic
auswählen oder locals oder tales oder
e-mails oder oder rocket ist der die
können sogar ansuchen die ich in dem
einfach mal ganz normal sonic ich kenne
mich ehrlich gesagt nicht so richtig
kommen sogar stage ist ich kann mich
nicht so richtig außerdem nicht als
notwehr stv gott ist das laut ich muss
hier irgendwie strecke lang fahren und
gegen die anderen gewinnen das spiel
sieht war total bescheuert aus aber es
ist wirklich neu ist längst ein bisschen
indem ich wäre es die benutze und mit
der kamera kann ich halt so ein bisschen
umschwenken die steuer nicht einfach mit
der maus das ich war wo war ich denn hin
ich bin tatsächlich gerade sind da von
allen das ist glaube ich der letzte
glaube ich jetzt konzentrieren auf die
strecke hier auch gott schafft das
geschafft ich kenne mich mit sonic nicht
so gut aus ich weiß halt nur das ist
halt irgendwie ich weiß woran ich habe
ich glaube ich noch nie gespielt auch
wieso bin ich da so langsam ich habe es
noch nie wirklich gespielt auf dem gba
damals doppelt guck mal ich bin fünfter
war halt immer wirklich viel mehr so der
super mario pokémon typ und sonnig habe
ich glaube ich nur gezockt als es
irgendwie war im happy meal so kleine
sachen davon gab ja ich habe es wirklich
noch höher mcdonald's sonnig war relativ
schnell und mit dem muss man dann eben
die levels bestreiten und so aber keine
ahnung vielleicht kann von euch jemand
irgendwo sonic in paris erklärt ich weiß
doch in letzter zeit irgendwie als nicht
pokemon hochgeladen habe kam auch sein
partner kanälen und habe ich richtig
angemerkt und malten sah wie gar nicht
wissen dass das die grafik ist und ich
denke benutze ich hab schild meine jungs
ja die einzigen games nicht früher
gezockt habe waren pokémon super mario
unter diese marken ableger wie mario
kart oder irgendwann und mit sonic und
zelda und so hatte ich irgendwie nie so
viel am hut aber das ist ein still to
bring it back to die old school so ein
bisschen kommt in vier teile überhaupt
nicht das gefühl dass ich irgendwann
hier überholen kann bekommt sofort ob
das hier so ein bisschen so diesen
oldschool charakter wieder zurück bringt
so das ist nämlich ein spiel muss scheiß
egal ist was die grafik macht also ihr
seht schon das ist total schlecht alles
aber es macht einfach spaß und das ist
ja irgendwie das wichtigste das war mist
ich mir also ein bisschen wie sie diese
call of duty leute die irgendwie jedes
call of duty im weltraum machen und ich
denken war geil future darauf hat jeder
bürger letztendlich fanden sie alle dass
theorie am besten muss einfach im
weltkrieg war die cod 4 war das glaube
ich auf einem rost finnische spurs das
ist natürlich totaler gerade aber da
frag ich bin einfach fix damals zweiter
und haben hewlett packard und sonic 69
player xxx dass das bin ich
lembeck mal bisschen die landschaft
nemeth später bild schmitz ach guck mal
die anderen kommen gerade alle ein ziel
ich volle einen berg hoch und bringen
jetzt tatsächlich jeden moment auf
weerberg sonnig dieses spiel bringt so
ein bisschen wie diesen old school
charakter von ja die grafik ist scheiße
dauert ein fucking fucks ist der große
von wegen grafik
aber ich bin halt ein mensch der bei
sowas wirklich nicht auf die grafik
achtet natürlich sind spiele wie keine
ahnung wer werden was hat der grafik gta
5 gta 5 ist auch was anderes geht vom
skisport geil das war das beste spiel
aller zeiten
a well dem schitt nein
fahrt mal live in letzer jazz im
gamestar grafik nice so aber dieses
spiel beinhaltet einfach spiel spaß und
die grafik ist scheißegal und das ist
jetzt der der ansporn ist dass ich
irgendwie erster werden und das ist
nicht so wie bei gran turismo dass ich
denke auch voll geil ich rate irgendwo
gegen und man
vieles kaputt und driftete nach links ab
so das ist einfach scheiß egal wo ich
gegen verhalten das einzige element in
diesem spiel ist die strecke und die
viele die fee wiese zwischen ziele die
ich erreichen muss und dieser typ da
hinten den ich jetzt gleich jeden moment
überholen werde
jb sechster und weiter hier über die
lava drüber und hier über die kurve ist
ich finds nur ein bisschen schade ist es
jetzt so keine attacken oder gibt es
attacken wenn es jetzt noch items geben
würde dann wäre es zwar sehr nahe an
mario kart dran aber das war cool dieses
ganze video ist wieder so ein nostalgie
schild wo ich einfach sagen dass ich
gottes den turm wo ich einfach sage was
ich in der gaming sache so ein bisschen
vermissen klein wie sowas zum heiligen
vater wieso bin ich dann am boden
stecken geblieben ich würde mich einfach
mal freuen und jetzt haltet euch fest
und verhaltet euch nicht fest ihr müsst
ihr nicht festhalten oder haltet euch
doch lieber fest für die idee ist glaube
ich echt doof wenn ich ein spiel machen
würde dann hätte ich richtig bock da
draußen übels behinderte spiel zu machen
wo ich einfach so einfach so random
irgendwelche sachen passieren
beispielsweise stellt euch mal vor ich
zog mario kart oder so und doch einmal
werde dir einfach vom spiel kriegt ihr
so gesagt okay ihr seid ihr gott das war
eng wird euch so vom spiel gesagt ja ihr
seid jetzt letzter oder stelle ich
spiele fifa und auf einmal reagiert eure
spiele einfach nicht mehr in ihren
elfmeter schießen wollt oder so das
fände ich ultra wichtig das wird total
unfair auf allen ebenen aber wenn ich
ein spiel machen würde dann wärst du
bekloppt das einfach irgendwelche random
aktionen passieren würden wo man sich
einfach nur denken hey warum
oder man spielt call of duty und hat auf
einem anstatt einer waffe ein dildo nach
wieso das wäre zwar so typisch shit
kurator game gold mäßig gastiert ich bin
13 sekunden schneller gerade aber das
finde ich einfach ultra cool und dann
würde ich auch im ficc auf die grafik
geben und da quasi genauso wie ihr das
ist einfach so typisches spiel spielraum
ein gott nein erfolg schnell sonnig aber
ich würde noch erster jammern alter
schweren ich hab nur gedacht okay davon
ist ihr ich guck mal auf dem tacho mich
noch einmal erster ich denke so geil ich
finde ich ja erst dann gebe ich hobel
kopf ich bin ja so ein hohlkopf aber ich
habe jetzt einfach mal diese fledermaus
hier ausgewählt und bin ich schon
abgemeldet nicht die tatsächlich auch so
aussehen wie diese mario kart rainbow
strecke und das witzige hier dran ist
halt irgendwie glaube ich dass ich
runter fallen kann wenn ich einfach mal
auch noch extra so oder so ich will
jetzt aber ehrlich gesagt gar nicht
testen ich habe allgemein mal überlegt
weil ich derzeit immer noch nach einer
neuen wohnung water fakt wie soll ich
denn da drüber kommen ich schau halt
derzeit immer noch nach einer neuen
wohnung weil meine jetzige wohnung bin
ich halt auch nicht so sehr zufrieden
wird weil auch schon ein paar mal fans
vor der tür stand und so ich mache das
alles nicht öffentlich dass mit den fans
schon zwei drei monate her
aber das war vielleicht doch nicht
ich dachte ich kann nicht anders hätte
report company ist nicht so ganz
lichtdurchflutet uns ein paar sachen mit
denen wir nicht belästigen will aber
viele leute interessiert sie einmal was
bei mir ab geflüchtet mir dann immer so
viele sachen so über die will ich nicht
reden so youtube mäßig mache ich mein
ding so leid meine videos hoch und alter
schwede bin ich ein bekloppter ach guck
mal da hinten auch darunter gefallen wie
blöd bin ich eigentlich in ordnung geht
okay es geht weiter ich bin gerade 35
sekunden meiner vorherigen runde und
muss jetzt wahrscheinlichkeit auch jeden
moment noch mal dieses komische looping
ding machen dann geht das kommt da
hinten er ist ja keine ahnung was ich
sagen wollte damit dass ich mir
vielleicht eine wohnung anschauen wollte
deswegen weil sie noch mal umziehen
wollte ist einfach weil ich dann noch
vielleicht ein gewinnspiel einfach
intermeat stelle und dann das ganze so
ein bisschen so dass meine fans kam
nicht immer so ein fettes ding ist dann
würde ich als ein green screen benutzen
und quasi anstatt an sondern sonst immer
als vermisst hat man quasi nur so hier
so abgeschnitten quasi alles nur das
blöde ist halt der green screen müsste
dann direkt hinter mir stehen und ich
musste irgendwie auf einem hocker sitzen
und könnte mich nicht anlehnen weil dann
der studie auch noch mit drin wäre und
überlege ich alles noch das geht auf
jeden fall jetzt bei mir ab und ich
wollte das video jetzt einfach mal
eigentlich wollte ich nur zocken aber
irgendwie bin ich dann wieder
abgedriftet in dieses jahr so geil
nostalgie voll cool alte spiele liegt
die grafik hauptsache spielspaß mäßiger
in euch sowas gefallen hat und ihr euch
denken ja luca es gibt aber noch zwei
strecken und sieben verschiedene
charaktere und sondern steht dann mit
einer bewertung wenn ich noch mal machen
soll wenn ihr solche spiele kennt wo es
einfach nur darum geht scheiß grafik
aber man kann irgendwas zocken dann
schreibe ich auch die kommentare und wie